from the very Earth that nourishes our
crops to the food we eat Agri food
systems are ever more susceptible to
mounting Global challenges further
aggravated by climate change conflicts
and pandemics pose a significant threat
to Global Food security and
nutrition in response nuclear techniques
and biotechnologies provide innovative
solutions to help us adapt and counter
the effects of climate change on Agri
Food
Systems at the Forefront of developing a
applying and disseminating these
Technologies and practices is the joint
FAO iaea Center of nuclear techniques in
food and
agriculture through its Agriculture and
biotechnology Laboratories research is
conducted to create solutions that
reduce the effects of climate change on
food and agriculture while promoting the
adoption of sustainable production
methods among member
countries starting from the groundwork
of agriculture culture the interaction
between soil water and nutrients in
cropping systems is carefully analyzed
through the application of isotope and
nuclear
techniques this allows to analyze soil
erosion and the effects of soil and
water conservation practices allowing
for the implementation of tailored
solutions to boost the productivity of
crop production systems these Solutions
are designed to reduce greenhouse gas
emissions enhance crop water efficiency
optimize fertilizer use improve water
management and combat land
degradation to increase crop resilience
to the adverse effects of climate change
new crop varieties are developed to
adapt to challenging climatic conditions
faced by member countries by applying
irradiation Technologies mutations are
induced at a higher frequency than
natural spontaneous
mutations the resulting crops varieties
are carefully bred through ctions for
traits such as tolerance or resistance
to harsh temperatures drought Pest and
diseases with changing climatic
conditions and global trade facilitating
the spread of insect pests across
borders into new regions the sterile
insect technique sit allows to induce
insect sterility through radiation
offering a solid solution to curb Target
insect
populations when used in an area wide
integrated Pest Management approach this
technique offers a sustainable means of
managing Target insect populations while
reducing insecticide
application livestock production and
health can be enhanced throughout their
entire life cycle thanks to the
application of nuclear and derived
techniques Research into optimizing feed
can reduce pasture degradation and
mitigate the greenhouse gas emissions
associated with animal agriculture to
ensure livestock can withstand changing
climatic conditions animal reproduction
and genetics are enhanced through
biodiversity
characterization the management of
animal and zoonotic diseases is Advanced
VI the application of nuclear and
related techniques helping to develop
and transfer animal vaccines rapid
diagnosis solutions for disease
prevention control and
eradication
changing climatic patterns are
increasing the uptake of heavy metals
pathogens and MotoX sins in food to
ensure that the food that reaches our
tables is safe and authentic food
analytical techniques to detect harmful
residues and contaminants in food to
ensure quality are developed and
transferred to member countries these
techniques include food eradiation
Technologies and standards as well as
food testing
practices this comprehens approach not
only reduces the risk of foodborn
illnesses but also addresses invasive
pests and food fraud safeguarding public
health and securing Market access
through the peaceful use of nuclear
techniques and biotechnologies the joint
FAO iaea Center of nuclear techniques in
food and agriculture develops and
implements Green Solutions to lessen the
impact of climate change and increase
food security
worldwide